[Musique]
je crois totalement à l'astrologie a
bien sûr que je crois à l'astrologie
j'aime beaucoup ça astrologie pas trop
sur ça parle
non là pour la voyance ou est ce que je
la pratique je tenais un peu les cartes
quand je sens des ondes peut prédire aux
gens ce qu'ils valent aura devenir où
ils peuvent me parler de moi voilà ça
crée du lien social prévoyance j'ai eu
des expériences assez assez étonnant oui
j'y crois j'y crois j'y crois à fond
m'apprennent des choses parfois ils sont
allés des 30
[Musique]
oui l'astrologie je connais bien étudié
les planètes j'ai étudié les placements
les mouvements tube lycées d'autruche et
ascendant vierge
voilà ensuite millions ascendant et voir
jacques richir
[Musique]
j'ai des copains qui ce qui ce qui se
dit ce voyant donc parfois ils disent
des choses qui se disent réalise je suis
allé voir plusieurs voiliers en toi
femme m'a dit je vois des choses il faut
que je vous parle alors vous tenez
j'avais été voir quelqu'un vous tenez la
semaine prochaine mais quoi semaine
prochaine elle vous dit que j'allais
travailler avec un secret mais qui
s'appelle cyril ont fait un match de
foot et je me suis défoncé le nez j'ai
vu une scientologues une vraie patiente
aurique de scientologie du scientifique
il m'a fait un un plan astral elle m'a
dit des choses qui me sont arrivées
effectivement sur les 20 années qui ont
suivi j'étais assez bluffé je veux dire
j'étais une fois j'ai toqué m'a dit
c'est qui je suis parti c'était voyant
leur moitié et chuter
[Musique]
dard alors oui c'est les add on à moi je
vois des choses terribles je vois je
vois
non vraiment d'action l'argent coule à
flots bobo d'oseille oulala ça c'est un
la boule merde je veux beaucoup de
berguette reiber quasi je sens de ma
claude ce sont beaucoup de ma propre ou
le lapin qui quitte à vous avez finir
dans une sandwicherie avoir des kebabs
oui ça c'est les sauces vous appelez
ajustant vous appelez géraldine nom
votre prénom avait pourtant gagné alors
vous êtes tous des rêves chez maxim's
getty le ventre arrondi pour vous à vous
êtes handicapé bon je ne vous dis pas
que vous allez remarquer tout de suite
parce que ça serait mentir
on va être honnête avec vous c'est
catherine c'est râpé et surtout bon 300
qui nous plaît
[Musique]